hey youtubers it's Charlie time for a
new game of Thrones Q&A just careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened
on the show so far so here we go let me
look at my questions here lots of
questions about cleganebowl lots of
questions about Jon Snow saying that
he's not coming back so here we go Emma
Dobson asks say you're a male bastard in
Westeros you've got a name like snow or
waters if the woman you marry has a
family name do you have to take hers or
do your kids have bastard names even
though their parents are married
obviously generally unless you become
legitimized through this act of marriage
she would have to take your bastard name
and your children would also have your
bastard name most of the logic behind
bastard names comes from Western Europe
and that really just applies to the
marital status of the parents so like
even if you're a royal bastard you're
still a bastard you get the bastard name
so there have been times in the past
when two Targaryen z' within the royal
bloodline have cheated on their other
Targaryen spouses with Targaryen
so imagine half of the Targaryen royal
family being married to the other half
and on the side they also swing within
the family any children born of any of
those unions would be bastards and would
have the waters name next question
Joshua asks did Ian McShane just confirm
cleganebowl 2016 well that also requires
you to have to jump through a couple
hoops what he did confirmed it did he's
probably playing the elder brother which
we all kind of thought I did a
gravedigger video back in November last
year so it kind of explains why Ian
McShane is probably the elder brother on
the quiet Isle and that is where we'll
see the character that he might be
bringing back trying to be as
non-spoilery as possible I'll put a link
for that in the description too you can
you can read all about it if you know
the gravedigger theory then yeah he is
probably totally coming back as for
cleganebowl though he'd have to come
back first and then they would have to
go back to King's Landing so it depends
on how soon he comes back which episode
that is in how soon they plan on having
the trial of the faith I'm really hoping
we see the trial by the end of the
season but gravedigger and cleganebowl
or two different theories but I think
the best way to put it is to say that
all ian mcshane confirmed is the
gravedigger theory but we might get
Clegane both there's not quite as much
evidence for Clegane bowl in the books
as there is for gravedigger theory but
if you want to believe cocaine Bowl I
don't want to pour any water on that
it's still totally possible
next question Michael asks do you think
that Jon would be able
so bright a dragon with ghost man's best
friend at his side well I don't know if
John will actually end up riding a
dragon but I do think he'd be possible
it's something that gets passed down
through the bloodline there are a couple
of hoops that you have to jump through
before that become possible they'd have
to confirm that he actually is part
Targaryen but it's a lot more
complicated than riding a horse the
science of dragon bonding isn't
something they've explained in a great
detail but if you've ever read the short
story the princess in the Queen is a
Targaryen Civil War that happened a long
time ago they talked a little bit about
dragon bonding if you want to read into
that next question Paul asks are we to
believe that Varys does or does not know
about the upcoming battle with the White
Walkers is he trying to find the best
leader for the Seven Kingdoms or the
best leader against the White Walkers or
is it both I would say definitely both
he just wants to make the realm stronger
he really hates magic I would think that
anyone that believes in magic is open to
possibilities but is someone in a
position of power who knows that there
are supernatural things that it's going
to take a strong realm to survive he's
just looking out for what he thinks is
the best interest of the realm
that's speech that he had at the
beginning of season 5 says it all you
know someone that the people will love
and rally behind in someone who's strong
enough to lead Robert Baratheon is a
good example of someone who only had one
of those two qualifications two really
important qualifications good leader in
someone everyone likes everyone liked
Robert Baratheon but he was a terrible
leader next question James asks why
didn't on Aaron tell Robert Baratheon
about Cersei and Jaime about the
twincest this question probably more
relevant for book readers and not
necessarily they talk about Jon Arryn
during the series I would think that he
was going to he just got killed before
he did they did explain during season
four of the TV show that Littlefinger
convinced Lysa Arryn to kill Jon Arryn
probably because Littlefinger knew about
the twincest and was working a long con
didn't want Jon Arryn to plunge the
realm into chaos before Littlefinger was
ready Varys would have probably also
supported that plan too he would have
eventually wanted to get rid of the
Lannisters too that only once his
replacement candidate was ready to take
the throne next question a me white wolf
vests
I just hope we get to see Rhaegar son
Aegon in the series if he indeed lived
from being switched were you talking
about a couple book thing
that I don't think the TV show is going
to do so in the books there's the young
Griff character who is secretly supposed
to be Aegon the lost son of Rhaegar who
was switched at birth so that the baby
that the mountain dashed against the
wall was someone else his role in the
narrative right now is to be another
challenger to the throne
there are several challengers like
Daenerys is a challenger to the throne
of Westeros Aegon comes along in the
books and it looks like he might try to
supplant Tommen what they might do on
the show because I don't think they're
gonna be doing young Griff on the TV
show is if they really want a character
like that another surprise candidate for
the throne someone with a legitimate
claim it would be a surprise Targaryen
it'd be very easy for them to use the R
+ L equals J Jon Snow Jon Targaryen
candidate for the throne but only after
some massive victories and big white
Walker battles that we have not seen yet
so that's assuming a lot of things I'm
just assuming they're gonna skip over
that storyline altogether and it'll be
Daenerys like Daenerys will march in and
it'll be a situation where like half the
citizens in Westeros support her and the
other half still support Tommen and
it'll be a game of Thrones between the
two of them but that's a long ways off
in the distance there's still so much
intrigue going on in King's Landing
right now especially with Cersei and
Margaery next question
Alberto asks do you think that the
writers and Jorge are Martin put in some
dialogue to throw off the Watchers and
readers are you talking you're talking
about like intentionally misleading
dialogue no I don't think they're
trolling people I do think that there
are things that get misinterpreted one
of the big things that we've learned on
Game of Thrones you know both in the
books and on the show is that what you
learn about history depends on who is
telling you that history so certain
people remember certain events certain
ways if you asked Robert Baratheon
what Rhaegar Targaryen was like he was a
is a stone-cold murderer and a rapist
but when Daenerys asked Barristan Selmy
what her brother was like he said oh he
was an amazing musician sometimes we
would get rip-roaring drunk go to flea
bottom and the money that he would
collect from people throwing coppers at
him he would donate to charity so when
characters are talking about other
characters especially events that
happened in the past really important
events you have to take that with a
grain of salt there's really only a
couple characters we know that can see
history as it actually unfolded but
they're probably going to dress that on
the TV
so I don't want to get too spoilery next
question George asks what do you think
about Kit Harington coming out in an
interview saying that he's indeed in
season six but only is the corpse of Jon
Snow do you think he's just lying to
give one more attempt to surprise us or
maybe he's telling the truth this is
also one of those sweet summer children
things where you have to take it with a
big grain of salt most of you who follow
Hollywood news are probably used to
directors and actors lying about what's
going to happen one of the more famous
examples that you probably remember is
when JJ Abrams was asked is Benedict
Cumberbatch playing Khan in the new Star
Trek movie this was several years ago in
JJ Abrams in front of a bunch of
journalists flat-out said no no he's not
playing Khan Khan's not in the movie he
flat-out lied to the press standard
operating procedure is non-disclosure so
when actors are blindsided by people
when they say hey you know as your
character still alive usually the
default mode and the studio support this
is for them to like tell them whatever
you want to tell them just don't spoil
it say anything you want it's not like
HBO is gonna get mad at kid Harrington
for lying and saying that he's dead and
never coming back the second part of
that though is reading between the lines
so like when HBO says as far as the
producers talking about Dan and Dave
have told us Jon Snow is dead so when
they say Dead is dead he's dead he's
bled out but when the fans say he's
coming back that's because we think he's
going to be resurrected you can't be
resurrected if you're still alive you
have to die first so that's why yeah
it's okay that he's dead HBO has said
that he's dead no one is lying about
that is just that we think that he is
coming back and there there's a lot of
stuff to support that I've probably
talked about it a bunch of times but
I'll put a link for my resurrection
video in the comments just explaining
all the ways that people have been
resurrected in A Song of Ice and Fire
there's more than one way people have
been brought back thank you everyone for
so many questions he's always a ton of
fun to do like I said the DVD comes out
next week hopefully that's when the
trailer drops if it doesn't we can all
riot everybody riot if the trailer
doesn't drop and I should say
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner alejandro serrano you win an
Amazon gift card for the DVD set be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so I get your contact details
I'll start a new round whenever I post
my next game of Thrones video so they're
really old videos I made them last year
a long time ago but you can click here
to learn more about resurrection and the
saga Meissen fire and you can click here
to learn about the gravedigger theory
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you